[Music]
so the average person like that's
something that i've noticed that what's
happening right now is that people are
throwing around these terms that for a
wall street investor are very common
terms but you hear these things like
margin and short
etc so when you're shorting a stock you
have to pay almost like a rental fee
to short it okay so this is
something that really has not been
discussed nearly as much as it should
i'm an expert in this stuff because i
literally battled against short sellers
my entire
firm was based on a long protracted
battle with shorts
because i was inflating stocks and they
were trying to short
yeah yeah exactly constant they tried
every trick in the book
and i squeezed them many many times the
problem is
is the shorts are very very clever and
the brokerage rooms are so corrupt that
so normally see the way it really works
is there's only one way you can really
there's two ways you can short a stock
legally one is if you
borrow the stock so you have a margin
account
and then you borrow the stocks so they
have what's called stock
loan departments and stock loans are
huge businesses on wall street very
profitable where they
lend people stocks that they charge fees
for that and that's why it's
and the purpose will break the law they
break every law to do stock loans it's
that
profitable it's massively corrupt right
yeah yeah that's number one
so you borrow the stock and then you
short it through a margin account that's
one way the other way the exemption is
through a market making account
knows you're a market maker on nasdaq as
a market maker in the normal course of
business
you're allowed to be long or short in
your position
as a normal course of just being a
trader in the market as a proprietary
trader
you're not allowed to be naked short as
a customer
it's against the law to be naked short
but what they do is
the brokerage rooms allow people like
these big funds to skirt the law and
stay naked short
through what's called prime brokerage
accounts and other accounts they just
allow them
to do things they should not be doing
and then what happens is they also
steal stock out of accounts that should
not
be uh stocks shouldn't leave those you
can't you you cannot
take stock out of a cash account only a
margin account
but what what happens is is that they
will take these stocks out
anyway these these firms are terrible
they take stocks out
and they illegally lend them out to the
short sellers and it's on and on it goes
and it's a vicious cycle you try to try
to it's time for my
stocks 200 of the stock was trading
they're short
two times over and yet they should be
being bought in as the phrase goes
but they're not because the the clearing
firms
are corrupt and they don't buy in the
shorts they're in cahoots with them
that's what's going on so in other words
people are shorting or
they shorted more stock than there
actually was
let me explain when you short a stock
you don't own that stock
right well guess what on a few days
later you have to settle the trade
yeah well you have to deliver stock to
make settlement you have
physical now it's not no longer physical
but it's physical delivery through
what's called dtc
it's electronically physically delivered
right but what happens is
is that if you don't if you haven't
bought the only way you could have it is
you borrowed
someone else's stock right and you
delivered borrowed stock
right but that's not what's happening
always they're allowing this to happen
because what will happen is you'll have
on any given moment you'll have what's
called
fails to receive and fails to deliver so
the person that
naked shorts to stock has a fail to
deliver they haven't delivered so on
settlement date
they're like where's the delivery so
then they give you a day to deliver the
stock
but then they don't actually buy the
person from doesn't buy that person in
it's a it's a very rigged game against
the little guy that's what's going on
so in in some way when you you are like
an insider so you know how like corrupt
the business is obviously you had some
corruption in the way that you ran your
business is that fair to say
yeah so do you oftentimes feel
like why am i the example every one of
these [ __ ] is doing something
corrupt
and i'm here as the bad guy and these
other guys are skating off
scot-free well listen you know when i
was in jail
right i did 22 months i used to say i'm
the only guilty man in shawshank like
i don't listen i did some things wrong i
smuggled money to switzerland
and i and i did my time and whatever i
deserved to get caught
the fact that everyone else was breaking
the same laws as me
doesn't make what i did right that's so
that's how i felt the time like
i was not even kneeling every single
firm was doing what i was doing
i was the biggest one out there and i
got caught and deserved to get caught i
went to jail fine
when i started to say maybe i didn't
deserve to go to jail
was in 2008 when i saw
goldman sachs bankrupting iceland and
greece
and i saw [ __ ] happening i was like what
the [ __ ] i'm like
i mean like dude i mean like i mean i
only lost some rich people money now
again it's not right but
compared to what they did i'm like a
choir boy and none of them went to jail
so yeah it started to get a little bit
maddening
back in 2008 and after at the end of the
big short
there's a scene and all the bad guys
went to jail
haha just kidding no one went to jail
yeah like i was like wow
i was sure they would crack down but you
know one of the big problems on on wall
street and
in politics and i think what what wall
street bets
is intuitively fighting against they
it's it's maddening
is this incestuous relationship between
wall street and
politics so we have like the former head
of goldman sachs is now the treasury
secretary
and vice versa and it goes on and on and
what they do is when they're in
government
they create laws that are these wide
loopholes that their buddies on wall
street can jump through
and it's sort of this this way where
they create this rigged game
the laws are written in a way to squash
the little guy
and favor large institutions and all you
see with these politicians
wave oh we're going to put a little guy
nonsense the sec is not for the small
investor
they're out there to screw the small
investor they protect the larger
firms and it's just such an awfully
terribly rigged
grain that's i was so gratified when the
guys from wall street bet says i thought
it was great i was like this is amazing
i wish i would have thought of it i did
and is the only thing that they did is
just
organize enough capital is that all wall
street bets was it's like hey if we just
connect
enough people will have enough capital
to go up against the hedge funds
partially yes partially no it was the
convergence of a bunch of different
things and i always listen i always said
guys
be really careful because at the end of
the day you know that stock is going to
have to come flying back down to the
earth
by the way there are many people on wall
street best that would curse me for even
uttering those words
yeah hold the line jordan don't be a
sellout
and and i you know and it's really you
know there's there's people there like i
could
support them he's an [ __ ] like
there's really
zealots on that wall street bets that
like it's just takes anybody that has
any sort of affiliation the institutions
in general must be evil
so you could be on their side and
they'll still hate you right so those
people are just whatever i don't care
they're just nuts right
but for the most part i think there's a
very a culture there of distrust
and they deserve to have that culture
what happened was a confluence
a convergence of events so what you have
is
at the same time that the power of
social media is
allowing people to connect in ways they
could never connect before
you have platforms enabling people to
trade
in real time without heavy trading fees
so you put those two things together in
the same
spot and combine that with a generalist
a general populist movement right now
that we see spreading all throughout the
country and the world
in different shapes and forms for
example you know you could look back
is what happened with trump but say it
was a populist revolt
against what's going on with the big
institutions like i don't care you could
hate trump but i just want to skarova
it's like it's a protest vote against
washington yeah right
i could then say and even if you and
even when you hate
trump as much as you can hate trump when
they deep platformed him
you might oh yay but in your stomach you
knew it was wrong
you knew it was wrong because you say
there's something wrong when when people
can be silenced
and the first amendment it can be just
stamped on like that
when you see big tech people being worth
hundreds a hundred billion dollars i
love elon musk okay
he's i think he's a wonderful guy but i
think generally he'd agree with this
that when you see this concentration of
wealth and
wall street flying like the dow flying
while
america is suffering in a pandemic when
you see people lock down their house and
can't go out to restaurants and gavin
newsom
is eating in the french laundry it you
know we take it on the chin take it on
the chin but in our stomach it
it's revolving so i think all of these
things are connected
into a moment of like there's a
zeitgeist anger here yes and
when you put money into the equation
like this guess what all of a sudden you
saw aoc
and ted cruz agree on something then you
know you really have
something that's really strange going on
yeah so i think that's really it's uh
you're right it's a populist movement in
many ways
yeah it almost feels yeah i was gonna
say that is kind of
parallel to what happened with trump
where people were
rejecting the political institution
right and this feels like a rejection of
the wall street or the banking
[Applause]
institution
you